- Okay.
- [Mark] So you were
gonna tell me something
about your childhood?
- Guess I'll do something
different today, yeah.
First off I was ten pounds, eleven ounces,
twenty-three and a half inches long
when I was born.
It took my mom two days to actually
give birth to me because I came out,
but just my shoulders, my head came out
and then my shoulders wouldn't come out.
They'd given her episiotomy, where they
clip you from your vagina to your rectum
to make sure you don't tear, but I tore
past that and they didn't know what to do.
I was at Children's Hospital in Sunset
over there in Hollywood and so after
about two days they decided that we were
both gonna die so they
just dismantled me and
pulled me on out.
'Cause he had reconstructed, you know.
She dilated, which means your--
- They didn't do a C-section?
- No, because my head was stuck.
My head came out, she reconstructed.
She had dilated, but then,
they went back together,
so she couldn't push my head back in,
and they couldn't pull me out.
So they decided to dismantle with me.
They took my shoulders apart or something
and pulled me on out and there I went.
Yeah, that's a story I heard anyway.
And, yeah, also when I was little,
I don't really remember much of this, but,
I mean the only memory
I have that I remember
from my childhood, I
probably have 10 of them
because of my PTSD,
was me crawling across the floor,
I was a toddler and I was
crawling across the floor
and there was people and
I was looking at them
and they were all talking and I thought,
"I hate this part.
"When am I gonna be able to communicate?"
You know, I just, it was
like, that's what I thought.
Like I'd done it before.
I've done this before and this
was the part I really hated
because I couldn't talk,
I couldn't communicate.
So my mom tells a story
of, when I was a baby,
I didn't speak, I didn't say
mama, baba, dada, none of that.
I didn't.
So, you know, for the
most part they thought
that I even had like some retardation
or I had a hearing problem or something
until me being that gigantic child.
The first time I was
able to crawl up my crib,
I crawled up my crib and
I went to my mother's room
and my mother was sleeping.
I would go over, I touched
her and, she sees me.
She's started, 'cause it's
the first time I've ever
climbed out of the crib and I
said, "Feed me, I'm hungry."
And my mother got up, she was terrified.
I'd be terrified too.
She was terrified.
She got up to turn on the
lights on in the house
and she started cooking
and calling people.
- Those were your first words?
- My first words were,
"Feed me, I'm hungry."
I didn't say anything until then.
My mom said she was terrified.
I mean, I think I'd be terrified too
if my child had never spoke,
woke me up in the night and
looked at me like this old soul
and said, "Feed me, I'm hungry."
She was, we couldn't figure out
why you didn't speak until then.
I said I probably wasn't
that hungry until then.
You know at 11 pounds
eight ounces, you know,
you get kind of hungry.
What else can I talk about today?
Let me see.
I grew up in Lake Arrowhead.
Well actually it's Crestline,
but I tell people Crestline
they have no idea where that is.
Most people don't even know
where Lake Arrowhead is,
I have to tell them Big Bear.
- You were talking about
your grandmother and coon.
- Oh, that was what I
want to talk about today.
I forgot, but he'll edit this part out.
- Yes.
- Let me see, yeah.
When I was young, I can't
remember exactly how old,
maybe, I don't know, nine or 10.
I had this friend and she was
my best friend and you know,
I lived in an area that was, you know,
kind of sheltered, you know,
I never really heard the grownups talk.
So I went to my grandma one day,
I would stay at my grandma's a lot.
I went to my grandma and I said that
I was gonna bring my friend home
and we were going to do
this project for school.
And her mom said it was okay
because her mom was going to go
and she had something
she could do that evening
and it would really help her out that way.
And my grandma said,
"Sure, bring her home.
"I'll fix some food.
"What should I make?"
I said, "Make one of your good meals.
"The good ones."
She said, "Okay."
And now my friend Andrea,
she was different than
everybody else at my school.
Different than everybody else.
And I was very, very proud
to have her for my friend.
She had these really
fluffy pompoms for hair.
She let me put my fingers in and touch it.
She let me touch it.
And her mom and her dad, they
were the really smart people.
You know, and I didn't quite understand,
I thought in the back of my head that
when I got really smart,
I would change and look
like they looked, you know?
Because they didn't have
those kind of people
where I was from.
The really smart people
like her family was.
So I come home one day,
I bring my friend Andrea,
her name was Andrea, I
don't remember names,
but I remember that one really well.
And I brought her home
and we go in the house,
and I remember my grandmother
looking like shocked.
And I turned around, I couldn't
figure out what was wrong.
And my grandfather then came into the room
and he snatched me up.
For the first time in my
life he put his hands on me
and he dragged me to the sewing room
and he proceeded to beat me telling me
who was I to bring a Coon in the house.
And I was like, "No grandpa,
"I swear ever since you told me
"I couldn't play with the raccoons.
"I haven't fed them, I haven't
played with the babies.
"I haven't done any of that.
"And I made sure that the wooden plank
"goes through the trash can lids
"so they won't get it and
make a big mess anymore.
"I swear I haven't."
And he was, I started coughing up blood,
he was kicking me and beating me
saying it was for my own good.
He was protecting me.
And I just thought, I was
just totally baffled because
grandpa's kicking me and he's hurting me,
and he's, it's for my own
good and he's protecting me.
I just, and what did that
have to do with the raccoons?
I haven't played with them,
I just was so, so confused
about this whole thing.
Now I wanted to tell this story because
the other day I had a
conversation with somebody
telling people that, you
know, everybody is prejudiced.
Everybody has preconceived
ideas and notions
about many things.
You know, but you don't have to go to be
a racist about that, you know?
My friend Andrea, she was black.
And I thought that her family,
I thought I was gonna look like
that when I got really smart
because her mother was
like a professional.
Her dad was like a judge or something
and they were just, the way
they carried themselves,
they just seem like this very,
like these creatures that were just like,
I wanted to be one.
You know, were very, very respectable,
but they were just, the
way they spoke was just
so classy and just so smooth to me that
I was just in awe, you know?
And I thought one day I
was gonna look like that.
I had no idea that my grandpa
was talking about my friend
until she came up and
she said, "It's okay,
"I'll go home now."
"No, you don't have to go home.
"He's just mad at me for the raccoons."
And she's, "No, that's not what it is.
"I'll see you at school tomorrow."
She says, "I'll talk to you then."
You know?
And then till I got to school the next day
when I was playing in her
hair at the break time,
then she tell me that a
Coon was a black person.
And I asked her, I didn't understand that.
I thought that I was gonna turn that.
I always thought I was gonna turn black
when I got to be really smart.
I always just couldn't
wait for that to happen
because I wanted to have hair like hers,
so I could play with it when
I went to sleep at nighttime.
You know, but my
grandparents or my parents
or any of these people in
my life when I was little,
they were supposed to be
nurturing me and teaching me.
None of that affected me.
I didn't wind up to be a racist, you know.
It's ignorance and fear,
that's all that is.
That's all it is.
You know, we have different
colors of skin because
when our tribes were put on this planet,
whoever was closest to the equator
got darker skin to protect them.
And the farther away you got from there,
you got lighter colored skin.
So, yeah, I was really
baffled when I was a kid
about that whole, you know,
'cause I didn't hear the grownups speak.
I didn't hear them talking all that
racist banter or anything.
It was just all of a sudden out of nowhere
getting dragged to the
sewing room, you know.
And I'll never forget that, you know,
I was terrified of my
grandpa at that very moment.
I'd never been terrified
of him ever before that.
I mean, he was my grandpa, you know,
if I pulled his ear his
teeth fell out, you know,
I had a whole different idea of my grandpa
until that moment, you know.
And I felt ashamed, you
know, when my friend told me,
I felt ashamed for that being my family
and I was upset because I
wasn't gonna be able to be that.
That I wasn't able to grow up and be them
when I grew up and got smart. Yeah.
- Tell me about your family.
I think we covered this once before, but
- My mother's Polish, my
father's French and Irish.
I was molested by all of them.
But when I was little, I
put it all on my stepfather.
I didn't allow myself to remember that
my father was doing it,
my mother was doing it.
You know, until much later,
until I was ready to understand that part.
- So you blamed your stepfather.
- Well, mine is an amazing mechanism.
You know, it protects you.
And I was young.
And he was molesting me.
He was the the one who
was putting me in sofa bed
and folding me up or sticking
me in the trunk of the car
to scare me so I wouldn't talk, you know.
And my father, you know,
see I used to have this
dream every night for years.
I had this dream where I
was going to a dark room
and then someone would be
taking it and push me down
and I'd feel this thing hit me,
I didn't know it was a penis.
And then he made me shove
my face in the crotch
and I'd be choking on it and then
when the whole thing was over,
I'd go to walk out the door.
And then right as I opened the door,
the dream would stop.
Until one day I opened the door
and I walked out my father's bedroom.
And that's where I realized
why all those years
I was so uncomfortable around him.
Why, you know, he always
wanted to have a massage.
I just dreaded going home and you know,
having to, you know, just all that.
And that was because of that, you know?
My stepfather, he was a schmuck.
I finally got to see him
after all those years.
To see my brothers, from him,
I had to go to a Christmas dinner one day
so I could see them, I've
never seen them before.
And so I went and he
followed me into the kitchen.
He got up next to behind me.
He goes, you were sexier
here when you were six.
I turned around and just went,
you were never sexy.
Get off of me before I hurt you.
And I pulled a knife out
of the kitchen drawer
I said "This is Christmas.
"Can we just have a good, I
just want to see my brothers.
"I don't wanna have any
interaction with you.
"Please. Let's not do that."
- And then where'd your
life go after you left home?
- Well (exhales heavily)
- 'Cause you had a legitimate job--
- See, my father was married six times.
My father was married six times.
He had five wives, he married one twice.
And the last one was this woman named Jean
and she was just this,
she wrapped her hair
up with lots of Aquanet
and wore this green eyeshadow
and she was, you know,
drunk at the bar and you know,
she just liked to be mean to me.
You know, for my junior
high school graduation,
she chopped my hair off
shorter than it already was,
kind of lopsided and
put me this ugly dress
and sent me on off.
You know, I remember I
walked by my father one day
and he went like this.
"Come here Becca, put your arms up.
"Where's your bra?"
I go, "I don't have a bra."
My first bra was a 36 C.
I didn't have a bra until then.
It was I went from a two
by four shape to, poof.
I had a woman's shape.
And you know, the first
time I had tampons.
She and I went to the
store, I look for Kotex.
I went to the store 'cause I had my period
it was my first day of my period.
She makes me pick it up
and she goes to the counter
and put your Kotex down
on the de-- (laughs)
Everybody knows everybody in that town,
I was just mortified I had to go up
and deal with this, you know.
I mean, she was just this,
one day this person said to
me that I had pretty eyes.
And I was like, and I was smiling.
I had my head down and she said,
"What are you smiling about?"
I go, "Nothing."
She's, "No, what are you smiling about?"
I go, "Well, he just told
me I had pretty eyes."
And she said, "That's
because he pities you.
"You're a freak, you know that."
So that carried on in my adulthood because
you know, people would say that I'm pretty
and then next thing you know,
somebody else is telling me,
you man looking bitch or something.
So I'm always waiting for when somebody
gives me a compliment for
the other shoe to fall.
So I bought her lie and it
affected me for most of my life.
You know, it still affects me.
I still have this complex
about the way I look.
But, anyway, she got so
mean to me that finally
I called up my mother
who I hadn't seen since
they took me away from
my stepfather and her
because I was being molested.
And, so, I called her and I asked her
if she wanted to have a daughter again
and she said yes.
So they came and picked me up
and she didn't tell me that she was now
trying to get away from him, Raymond
'cause he was stalking her
and doing all this stuff.
The only good thing about my childhood
was I was raised in something stable.
You know, I knew there was
a house that was the house,
you know, and I go down there
and she didn't have a place to live.
We had to live in the
living room of her friends.
And that was just really
difficult for me to,
you know, get accustomed or,
you know, I just couldn't,
it was really hard for me.
The harder part was when,
I found out my mother was gay
and the woman she was
smashing was masculine,
and wanted me to touch her accordingly.
I just wasn't able to do that.
So I took off and I had friends,
these friends, we were in Hollywood.
I mean, so I was kind of
a Holly because I was like
a Santa Monica Boulevard, fruit fly.
I was a fag hag, I didn't want to change.
I just, that's where I hang out.
I feel comfortable there.
For a long time, you know,
people told me I was gay.
I'm gay?
See, 'cause a child
when they're growing up,
when they're adolescent, they're growing
and they're creating
their self, sense of self.
Like, who I am, what I
like, what I don't like.
Well, I had never had that because
when somebody came through the door
I had to go, "Oh, what do I have to do?
"How do I have to act to survive
"the situation with
this person?" You know?
And so I never created a me,
it was always, "What do you like?"
"I don't know, what do you like?"
You know, "What color?"
"I don't know what color do you like?"
"What do you want to do?"
"I don't know, what do you want to do?"
I never had the sense of me, you know?
And so, I don't remember
I was talking about now.
I never had the sense of me.
So anyway, I went to Hollywood
and every time people
were telling me I was gay
and so, okay, I'm gay and then,
no, no you're not that kind of gay,
you're the other gay girl.
You're the masculine one.
So, I'm like.
So I became that because that's what I do.
And until one day I just
decided I wasn't gay.
And it was really hard because
there was always people
and I was quite popular and
all these kinds of things.
And all of a sudden, whew.
You know, I had a good
job, I had the cool car,
I had, you know, all these things.
Cool girlfriends and I was just like,
I'm just not, I'm just not gay.
I'm tired of being what I
have to be for everybody else.
You know, it was hard to be me
because I don't know what me is
and at first I had to be kind of
embarrassed of me because, you know,
because everybody thought
of me as something else.
It was hard for me to be what
everybody expected me to be.
It was hard to live up to that.
So it was really hard for me to live up to
what I wanted to be.
- People are all freaked out right now
about this coronavirus.
- Me too at times, but--
- But it seems like to me,
the immune system of these
people down here seems to be--
- I've had pneumonias that were so bad
that for 45 days I couldn't even see
the light at the end of the tunnel.
I was so weak and so drained.
And then, I get up for
45 days I get on my bike
and I get about from here
to you and I have to stop,
get off the bike and lay
down on the sidewalk.
I was just like, couldn't do it.
I just couldn't do it
and and I survived that.
I can't imagine it being
any worse than that.
You know, I just can't imagine it.
- And you got past that with
with antibiotics or without?
- Without, because see,
I went to the hospital.
I went to the hospital
because it got so bad.
I went to the hospital and I
was hacking and it was just,
I mean, I couldn't stop
coughing and it was just,
I was so weak and I was freezing cold,
but I had this fever and I went in,
I check in, I sit down
and all of a sudden,
"Hey lady, you can't fall
asleep on the floor there."
I was like, "Oh, I didn't
know I was on the floor."
You know what I'm saying?
I go, "Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry."
I get back in the chair.
I don't know how long,
seconds later again,
"Lady, I told you you can't."
(whispers)
The third time, this lady tells him,
"Look, she doesn't mean to,
"she's sitting there, all of a sudden
"she just does a nosedive,
doesn't even protect herself
"when she hits the ground.
"She's out."
And I went to do it again and he came in,
I'm like this, "Check this out.
"I'm not so good at that
"stay on my chair thing obviously.
"So maybe you need to get me a bed.
"Because I'm trying my hardest.
"Or tie me to my chair
cause I'm trying my hardest
"to stay in this chair.
"I just am not capable of doing that."
And I got well I mean, but you know.
I can't imagine it being
much worse than that.
And if it is, then I won't
care 'cause I'll be dead.
I have to remind myself when I get scared
there are no mistakes in life.
- Hopefully we'll all get through it.
- Right, there are no mistakes in life.
What's going to happen is going to happen,
I can't change that.
It's just going to happen.
The best thing to do is not be too careful
and too scared or too
angry or too, you know,
acting out, you know, displaced anger
while going through because
what happens is going to happen.
If you go through it, be happy until then.
If you die, you won't care
'cause you'll be dead.
(laughs)
I mean, isn't that the basically?
I mean, then you'd be like,
(exhales sharply)
I wish I'd done that long time ago.
- Alright, Reilly, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- Thank you very much.
- It was nice to hear your
whole little life story,
- I got a lot more of it.
- Yeah, I'm sure we'll
do this many more times.
- Come back for a chapter.
- Whatever.
- Okay, that's good.